of the lord and i don't have to
physically put people in harm's way this
comes even as churches in nevada now
have new covet 19 regulations a federal
court overturned an order tuesday that
upheld limited gatherings saying houses
of worship can have 25 percent of their
capacity
instead of the 50 person limit put in
place by governor steve cesalac
cantor jessica hutchings with
congregation near tamid says they're
also
fully online they even stopped parking
lot services when the statewide pause
was announced last month
we have a committee of doctors and of
board members that make decisions based
on what our government is advising and
what is
safe for our community so we will be
meeting to discuss
how and if this changes anything that
we're doing right now
church goers we spoke to say they'll
continue to stay home
i'm afraid of what would happen
i think it's better to do it virtually
but i just want to be on the safe side
so right now i don't go to church
basically while some look forward to
in-person services during the holidays
pastor west has one simple message
this season i just want people to be
safe that's my prayer
governor sysolak said in a statement
that he was disappointed
in the court's decision but he will
follow it he's also still
urging congregations and churches that
choose to hold
in-person services to be safe by
requiring masks
and strict social distancing reporting
live in las vegas tonight orco mana 8
news now